the reason we don't really understand
the inverse trig functions is because we
just started using it and punching into
our calculators before we started a bit
further back engagement context okay so
on your heading if you if you wrote it
the right way where we need to begin is
not the most root functions but with
functions and relations okay which is
something you might have looked at the
end of you night and you might have no
memory of because you know often it's
gone just before the exam or even after
the yearly exam
it goes out of your brain pretty fast
okay sorry make make this the heading is
alive
Alyssa Sherman remember what functions
and relations will start with relations
first in reality right now sorry
question you're gonna give it okay we
come up with related numbers all the
time okay pairs of related numbers often
okay so for instance something's mass
tends to be related to its size yes okay
the temperature outside tends to be
related to time okay and I've got on and
on these when you whenever you've got
two quantities or values or variables
that are related to each other we call
that a relation right it's a
relationship and if you can express it
mathematically you could write it as an
equation okay so for instance that's a
relation okay
that's a relation you see there's a
connection between the two numbers okay
they're not independent flying off from
doing whatever they like when one does
something it affects the other okay
now functions functions are
subset of relations okay they are the
special kinds of relations where now
does anyone know what the difference is
yeah stop stop now okay fine
I'll get to that in a second but let's
just come back okay what does it have to
do with when you've got two numbers
what's the what makes a function when
you've got to like like say size and
mass or time and temperature what is it
what characteristic about those two
makes it a function
more specifically not just a relation
okay now the answer is right there each
let me get this right for a function
okay each output each input has only one
output okay so you should get that down
that's a really important idea okay
because it's gonna come back and bite us
to make that stop thinking about
treating Monday it implements only one
output down cartesian terms which is
what richard who jumps you okay that
means each x because we we call that
into its x usually right each X has only
one y value to go with it
okay I'll get to that in a second so
let's just think in general terms now if
you wanted to test how that would on how
that would work out okay let's have a
look at these for instance again I
probably should ever use that
so what does that look like as a as a
graph of that function goes across
geometrically what you can do is the
they call the vertical line test right
because if you take a vertical wire that
means for each x value you'll check how
many Y values there are okay and the
number of times your vertical line
intersects you know for instance once
once once once once once once okay for
all values this is only one output
that's what classifies is a function of
course when you move to other kinds of
relations if you slap the vertical
whining right
well for all over the host or is this
one this relation exists except for ya
here that vertical line is going to get
twice right so you've got two outputs
for each input which is why this is no
longer a function all right now if
that's what functions are relations are
how do they relate to inverses how would
you define an inverse in like in English
in plain language without without
talking about X's and Y's
you don't need once and outputs what is
it inverse you switch them around switch
what around equals with you so what does
that mean negative reciprocal maybe
defends just now okay we're trying to
get at what is it returns you know what
does swapping inputs and outputs mean
okay so for instance if I took on if I
took this here okay and swap them okay
well what's that about what's the
purpose of that and the answer is the
reason why this is important why we call
it an inverse is because it actually
sorry not actually it specifically
reverses the process if this does okay
so this takes it input right
we're going this one and Hobbs it okay
so there's a process and you've only
have one output for every input that you
put in okay but what is this - it takes
your input and it doubles it which is
exactly the opposite its undoing what
this does if you're lying okay
so again in cartesian terms you swap
your X and what okay now this is a
function alright and if we graph this
right what you get is also still a
function right because I can do my
vertical line test so this is an inverse
I'm sure they're problems okay but you
can imagine right it's not that hard to
think of examples that you can start
with some functions and when you do the
inverse you swap your x and y's you're
not gonna get a function back okay can
someone give me an example okay so let's
take this guy okay Mike was expert is it
a function it is it is right because
when you graph it you put your vertical
line across and it always intersects box
it's only ever white happily okay but
what's the inverse of this well you just
swap around your inputs and outputs so
let's do that
okay now I've swapped them this is the
proper inverse function now what does it
look like make yourself a new axis okay
so there is x equals y squared okay and
it is clearly not a function okay so it
is the inverse but it's a relation right
okay now we can do things to this so
when we take the inverse you'll just get
a function and what would you do and the
answer is yeah you place some kind of
restriction okay
now let's think about this I actually
have some choice right um where should I
place
the restriction I can put in one of two
places if all they want to do is make an
inverse function okay so if all I want
to do is make an inverse function any
inverse function then either of these
choices would be fine I can take this
domain over yeah X is less than or equal
to zero or I can take the other side now
quick question by the way why is it that
0 the origin why is it this is the point
where I do one or the other why can't I
go like say here over there or why is it
that point what's special matter more
specifically you're on the right track
there it's the turning point right and a
turning point is what breaks the breaks
the inverse relation over here when it
turns that's when you said start to fail
the vertical blind test
okay just file that away right the
reason why I'm choosing the domain here
why this is the switching point is that
that's where the turning point is okay
now suppose I chose the met enzyme what
would be the inverse function if I only
took the left hand side and took the
inverse of that what would be the
inverse function of that restriction in
the demo - okay so if I I'm gonna do it
geometrically okay so you remember one
of the ways that you can go from a
function to its inverse is you flip it
you're reflective but where do you
reflect it
okay so two difference they're both fine
you can take that line right back there
4.5 degrees that's y equals x and if you
turn your head that's how we're I'm
gonna flip it
okay I'm gonna reflect it across that
line so what are you gonna get you're
gonna get this line that looks
symmetrical once you turn your head
properly yeah it's pretty good now
what's the UM what is the equation of
that inverse function okay what it's
underneath the axis right for all values
of X so I know there's gonna be a minus
at the front okay and the rest of its
characteristics I get from this right so
I would take this square root sign with
the bottom okay now that would work just
fine okay but why wouldn't why would we
you know avoid that kind of campus
function why wouldn't we choose that
some suggestions you know why it's maybe
not the best choice negatives are lame
James access to be bigger than 0 yeah
X does have to be 0 but if I took either
one it should still be greater than 2
you'll always be yeah exactly so the
range in domain is swap now the reason
why I probably suggest why it's like
that's a weed way to go is that square
roots and squares they often come with
measurement our distances okay so will
be a weed if you thought now what's the
way to reverse this
let's take negative values okay that's
unusual that doesn't fit the use cases
for you know why we take the inverse
function okay so therefore if Cardo
makes more sense to just take this side
right and that's why we mainly that's
why the calculator will give you the
positive values because we've told it to
right not because there's something a
thing but this makes more sense to us
okay and you can see you know if a
student
that's where the shame comes from again
you can turn your head and you can see
the symmetry so this idea of taking a
function and restricting its domain in
such a way that you get an inverse
function path okay it's really critical
okay in fact it's gonna be the building
block for when we move to inverse trig
functions especially the fact that you
can choose lots of different ways to do
it